We claim that run.py is fast, very fast.
So let's confirm this.
But before that, we need to learn
how to time a particular operation.
We need to import a library for that.
We import the time library to help
us know how fast our operation is.
We use the time function
from the imported library.
The idea is to capture the time
snapshot before the operation, and
then again capture the time snapshot
after the operation is performed.
We then subtract the two times.
Simple, right?
Let's check the code.
Here we will check how much time
a Python print statement takes.
So we capture the time before
the print statement and
then record the time after
the print operation is performed.
Then, finally, subtract t2- t1.
Let's run the code, now.
Here, we get the time taken
by a print statement.
Oh, the number is really very small.